POCKET NOW.
>> Ryan: ON THE ATTACK.
BACK TO A
TIME-OUT.
CENTER.
THERE.
NICE LITTLE PUSHALLEN.
THERE GOES
>> Austin: COMPLETE HAND ON THE
BALL.
GET THAT S SUCKSMART.
>> Hubieie LATE SITUATION, LEAD
LOCKER ROOM.
MICHELLE, G G
JR. AGAINST DANIEL GAFFORD AND D
LOOK AND WATCH COLE GET TO THE
BALL AND THATND THE THIRD AND BS
TO SHOOT IT RIGHT THEN.
YOU JUST  WILLIAMS.
IN THE REVIEW CONTINUES. HAVE K
INJURY
[LAUGHTER]
>> Eddie: DON'T DO THAT. TURN A.
THREW IT AWAY AND A A LaMELO BA
>> Bob: THE BALL
AROUND POWELL.
TO POWELL, WHAT FOOLED.
HE GOES RIGHT TO THE RIM AND IS
ATHLETIC ENOUGH TO
THE HASHTAKEOFF.
HE IS NOT GETTING HIS WAY.IT ST
THE WAY HE SHOT IT.
HAD ENOUGH ENERG IT UP AND IN W
OF